♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT HAS REJECTED THE
FINAL APPEAL FROM AN PRISON
FORMER ILLINOIS GOVERNOR RABBLE
GARBAGE, GUARANTEEING HE'LL
REMAIN IN PRISON.
FOX'S MATT FENN      VAN HAS MOR
FOX'S MATT FENN      VAN HAS MOE
FOX'S MATT FENN      VAN HAS MOT
FOX'S MATT FENN      VAN HAS MO.
>> TUCKER, THE U.S.
GOVERNOR'S APPEAL AND NOW HE IS
BASICALLY GUARANTEED TO BE
BEHIND BARS UNTIL 2024 UNLESS
THE PRESIDENT PARDONS HIM AND
THE TWO HAPPEN TO KNOW EACH
OTHER.
HE APPEARED ON THE PRESIDENT'S
FORMER REALITY SHOW
"THE APPRENTICE."
BACK IN 2012, HE WAS FOUND
GUILTY OF SEVERAL CORRUPTION
CHARGES MOSTLY RELATING TO
CHARGES OF THE SELLING
BARACK OBAMA'S SENATE SEAT AND
IT WAS UP TO HIM TO FILL HIS
SEAT.
HE WAS TAPED BY THE FBI SAYING
IN PART THAT OBAMA'S VACANT SEAT
GOING TO GIVE UP FOR NOTHING.
THE DISGRACED GOVERNOR INSISTS
HE NEVER RECEIVED A BRIBE OR A
KICKBACK.
HE HAS BEEN THE FEDERAL PRISON
SYSTEM SINCE 2012 AND HAS FIRED
A SERIES OF APPEALS WHICH OF ALL
BEEN DENIED, TURNED DOWN ONCE
AGAIN TODAY IN THE HIGHEST
COURT.
BEFORE BLAGOJEVICH WAS APL MIKEI
BEFORE BLAGOJEVICH WAS APL MIKEN
PRISON, HE WAS KNOWN FOR HIS
FLAMBOYANCE AND FALL FROM GRACE.
TUCKER?
>> Tucker: MATT FINN, THANKS A
LOT FOR THAT.
WRITING IS NOW IS PATRICIA
BLAGOJEVICH, THE WIFE OF THE
FORMER GOVERNOR.
MS. BLAGOJEVICH, THANKS A LOT
FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING.
>> Tucker: I WAS NEVER A
SUPPORTER OF YOUR HUSBANDS, BUT
I HAVE TO SAY I THOUGHT HE GOT
AN AWFUL LONG TIME IN PRISON.
I DON'T KNOW THE DETAILS BUT I
WOULD BE INTERESTING IN KNOWING
IF YOU CAN SPEAK TO THE
PRESIDENT, WHAT WOULD YOU SAY?
WHAT WOULD BE OUR PITCH FOR
PARDONING YOUR HUSBAND?
>> WE WERE SO DISAPPOINTED THAT
THE SUPREME COURT DID NOT DECIDE
TO PICK UP OUR CASE.
IT'S A VERY DANGEROUS CONFLICT
WE HAVE AN ALARM RIGHT NOW.
PROVIDE CLARITY THAT WE HAD
HOPED FOR.
CLARITY THAT BOTH ANYONE WHO
RUNS FOR POLITICAL OFFICE AND
ANYONE WHO DONATES THOSE
POLITICAL CANDIDATES REALLY
NEEDS.
THIS IS SO DANGEROUS BECAUSE IT
ALLOWS THE FBI AND POWER-HUNGRY,
OVERZEALOUS PROSECUTORS LIKE
PATRICK FITZGERALD, WHO
PROSECUTED BOTH MY HUSBAND AND
SCOOTER LIBBY, TO GO AFTER
ANYONE THAT THEY DON'T LIKE JUST
BECAUSE THAT PERSON MIGHT BE
UNPOPULAR OR CONTROVERSIAL.
MY HUSBAND IS PROBABLY THE ONLY
PERSON IN THE ENTIRE HISTORY OF
THE UNITED STATES WHO IS SERVING
ANY KIND OF SENTENCE FOR SIMPLY
ASKING FOR CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS.
>> Tucker: HOW MANY YEARS DID
HE GET?
>> IT'S A 14 YEAR SENTENCE.
HE NEVER TOOK A BRIBE.
NEVER TAKE A KICKBACK, NEVER
MADE ANY PROMISES TO CONTRIBUTE
YEARS FOR ANY OFFICIAL ACTS.
WE NEVER TOOK GIFTS, TRIPS,
CARS, WATCHES, ANYTHING OTHER --
THAT OTHER GOVERNORS HAVE BEEN
CONVICTED OF, AND YET HE IS
SERVING A SENTENCE THAT IS TWICE
AS LONG AS ANYONE ELSE.
>> Sean: DO YOU SEE HIM A
LOT?
>> WE GO OUT, HE'S BEEN OUT
THERE SIX YEARS.
HE IS IN COLORADO AND WE LIVE IN
CHICAGO.
THE FIRST COUPLE OF YEARS, WE
WERE OUT THERE QUITE A BIT.
NOW WE GO OUT THERE ABOUT FOUR
TIMES A YEAR.
WE STILL TALK ON THE PHONE EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
MY DAUGHTERS ARE GROWING UP.
MY OLDEST -- MY OLDER DAUGHTER
IS A SENIOR IN COLLEGE.
SHE'S GRADUATING IN TWO MONTHS.
MY YOUNGER ONE IS IN HIGH SCHOOL
MY YOUNGER ONE IS IN HIGH SCHOO
HIGH SCHOOL.
THE ABILITY TO PULL THEM OUT OF
SCHOOL TO SEE THEIR DAD, IT GETS
HARDER AND HARDER.
>> Tucker: I ALWAYS FEEL, NO
MEN IN PRISON.